canned tobacco sauce
tobacco sauce tabasco sauce what is
tobacco's on
like chew like a dip cup i think chew is
tobacco sauce tabasco sauce can that
kill sperm is tabasco sauce spermicide
and do we really think drake put it in
i hope he did you gotta explain the
story okay so basically what's happened
is there was an instagram thought uh
this is the huge allegedly okay
instagram thought and drake link up
drake's put the drake puts the smash on
okay
um
put a condom on he described his penis
seven inches
and yo drake kind of looked thick man
i'm not going oh hey he's a thicker dude
yeah he's not he's not skinny adds up
you don't look like you got skinny beard
yeah thick beard
look at his head is thick
doesn't he have like a wrestler head a
little bit he's a kind of thick head
yeah like his head kind of looks like
one of them um
stone sculptures oh like easter island
easter island
yes he's got a little bit of a beast
yeah that's what he used to look downsy
in the beginning he had a little downs
now he's good
where he grows yeah he did glow up and i
think he's doing something with the
eyebrows to like make it look a little
bit less downs
because the eyebrows look like a
thatched roof like i remember once i saw
ninjas crawling on his eyebrows
and look they were sneaking in to do
something but it turns out the guy's not
downs
and he's putting tabasco sauce in
condoms which is absolutely [ __ ]
brilliant high iq points there very
bouncy why that's more ozzie that way
that's like more yeah maybe you know
he's on a spectrum see this is the thing
that a lot of people are assuming we're
assuming he put the tabasco sauce in
there to kill the sperm but you ever
seen like a mexican with some cheetos
and then they take some yeah you might
have been getting
like a latina exactly like he might have
been throwing it in there right and then
that's like a delicious treat yeah
exactly for him or her who knows okay
i can see either who knows you don't
know what these people are into we don't
even know what this girl is if that
girl's latina there's a chance that she
was so drunk she thought it was a bag of
fritos it had some hot sauce in it and
then she just started pouring in her
[ __ ]
like the mangoes on the street exactly
mangoes they put hot sauce on it 100
percent what's to say that latinas don't
want also to have hot sperm if latinos
like everything hot why would they not
want some hot sperm he's just trying to
cook things up for you know what i mean
100 i think that's where mexicans come
from hot sperm yeah i think it's just
tabasco with a [ __ ] that's right yeah
i think this is possible i'm not
positive though this is definitely
possible okay the logic adds up what's
that the logic adds up the logic
absolutely now do you guys really think
that he did that
i want to think that he did that so i
choose to think that he did that okay
you're true to thinking absolutely
thanks which makes me feel like you
might have a little insider information
over here
into their [ __ ] that's another level of
fame nah girls do that [ __ ] emptying
condoms into their posts yes yeah yeah
i've heard about this just can you
imagine them with like those huge fake
nails trying to undo the condom no you
don't want to do it you just cut a hole
in the top and pour it in like you're
designing a cake oh [ __ ] mark that was
pretty good thanks it's great british
bake off but like
it really is great british bake off they
just poke a hole in the bottom and then
you can write the name or happy birthday
on the clip oh my god yeah whoa
write the name on the top of it like a
host is like a like a cookie that is but
that is kind of wild
that is kind of wild that you reach a
level of fame where you have to destroy
your sperm even though it's in a condom
and of another question i have is has
that ever worked a girl has used the
sperm that was in the condom to get
themselves pregnant after the fact i
could see it working
the first episode of ray donovan it's
just it's just a bag of sperm bruh yeah
but it's spermicide in the condom
spermicides i wouldn't know about
condoms i don't really know how long
sperm lasts for bro
how long the sperm lasts for sun is in
there swimming bruh say what it's in
there swimming dog
it's not out in the atmosphere once it
leaves your dick it's got to have a
shelf life in like 10 seconds unless you
put in the freezer and then it could
last a long time yeah but now you're
busting right into the freezer
and then they take that cup and they put
it into a freezer yes so if you're
busting to the condom you got a little
time yeah i'm saying you got a good half
hour probably
wow this could work
this could absolutely work
i don't think this is my this is my
theory i don't think it's real i think
that drake is a brilliant marketer and
he's like i'm gonna lean into people
believing this is real and i'm gonna fan
was it fan the flame a little bit and
now we're out here talking about it
because it's an absolutely phenomenal
story and 100 he does have to worry
about who he is pregnant yes yeah so
according to this if it's in like a
regular room temperature room and it's
not like super hot or super cold yeah
you could put sperm in a condom it
apparently could last for up to two
hours can it last with hot sauce in it
google can a sperm last with hot sauce
if it's tabasco so you gotta do some do
some [ __ ]
heat units
but i'm saying tabasco probably tabasco
because they got them small balls you
could fit in the pocket and it's got mad
vinegar in it vinegar probably kills
[ __ ] it's a [ __ ] it's an antiseptic i
think
so you know what i mean that's probably
what it was now was the girl beyonce
because she has hot sauce in her bag
swag
that would be crazy this is the blackest
that would be craig has ever been that
would be crazy
no disrespect to jay no disrespect to
jay but that would be absolutely crazy
that would be crazy but you were never
worried about this back in the day
what's that you maybe have a condom
laying around someone could you know
scoop it up never worried about that not
one
come on bro no i never worried about
having a condom lying around i just
would never use condoms
who's using condoms
i'm getting my dick sucked
drake and this guy's on tv
girls were trying to watch me
after it mattered
i mean i know that she ain't doing
nothing for me
you came in late brother
these girls with snatching condoms and
trying to dump it into their cooters
for real man it was a problem out there
miles go back to your drawings
wait what it was a reddit thread from
nine years ago the title is how do you
ensure sperm is not stolen from a condom
top comment nine years ago tabasco sauce
works
wow i also read about a case a while
back where a guy hot sauced his condom
because he suspected his girlfriend was
taking them out of the trash trying to
get herself pregnant one night after a
sec she comes into the room crying from
pain and tries to charge him with
assault
how is that so that's the crazy thing
about this story that we didn't discuss
she's suing him allegedly yeah i don't
believe this is real yeah but allegedly
she's suing him and that chick over
there
tried to charge a boyfriend with assault
it's like once i'm not in that condom
first of all isn't that still my
property yeah that's mine that's not
shared property yeah you threw it out
so now it's just garbage it's the cities
she went dumpster diving she went
dumpster diving but then when you
dumpster dive for something if you
dumpster dive and then a knife cuts you
you consume me yeah hmm that's a good
ass question you're jumping through the
garbage looking for random things
lance you can't do that come on what if
it's your gun and it has your prints on
it and all that type of [ __ ] you just
threw it on the gun
isn't that why krispy kreme like locks
up their donuts why
locks up their dumpsters because they
throw stuff away and then people eat it
and if they get sick they could
potentially charge because it's on their
property this is interesting here now
it's on their property
this is still on drake's property if you
slip and follow drake's house
potentially hotel hotel's not nobody's
property that's the hilton got to worry
about that yeah that's the marriott's
problem that's the anatole got to worry
about that
that walks into drake's house signs
release
this is his hotel though but this is the
hotel
this is a hotelie also why don't you
just put your condoms in somewhere else
all right guys we're gonna take a break
from this exclusive patreon clip you can
get the full episode of patreon.com
flagrant2 uh but i gotta tell y'all
about how to keep your dicks hard matter
of fact how to give the best dick of
your life and that's blue chew very
plain and simple okay your girl deserves
it ladies if you're watching right now
you deserve it your wife deserves it
your side chick deserves it everybody
deserves that good dick and you're gonna
deliver it with blue chew and you're
gonna deliver it for free all you gotta
do is go to bluechew.com okay use the
promo code flagrant and you're gonna get
that first batch for free all you gotta
do is pay five dollar shipping that's it
bluetooth.com
use the promo code flagrant get that
dick and deliver it now let's get back
to this exclusive patreon clip also why
don't you just put your condoms into
somewhere else like i don't get why you
gotta throw it away i always flush the
condom down the toilet yeah why don't
you do that
you're going to stop up the toilet
that's not supposed to get full it's the
barrier
[ __ ] about their toilets so you was
doing that at home too
i flushed condoms always it's the city
he doesn't live on septic yeah what's
the worry yeah there's like so many
apartments in my building also i ship
four times a day it's ready to go well
that's that's different you gotta throw
it in the backyard
i actually knew a person who put so many
condoms in the toilet oh did you
they chopped out of oak tree in the
front yard because the safety tank had
to get the move oh [ __ ] damn boy how
many cars he was jerking off in back in
the day
yo you got a time before you flush them
if you don't have time before they flush
them then the [ __ ] gets [ __ ] up why
would that work
they get filled with water it turns into
a real balloon
right that's how you clog the whole
thing
bro it's like an artery bro
you have all these full balloons there's
water rushing through they're expanding
and everything is blocked up
that's why you got to tie the knot at
the top not so these [ __ ] don't pour in
our cooter
it's really because it will blow up
within the uh plumbing system
no it's not
true
same thing why girls can't put their
tampons in there wait why
because that also blows up yeah i never
seen a tampon going water or cranberry
juice yeah i guess yeah
yeah cram rage is more like a period
yeah he's talking about the commercials
from yeah okay
also they use the blue water in the
commercials
when they use red and the commercial
dudes were like yo get this groceries
[ __ ] tv what the [ __ ] is going on
over here
football dude gets concussed he's just
bleeding out of his nose totally okay
that's a gladiator it's a glitter
gladiator
a [ __ ] tampon goes into red ink yeah
get that hypothetical horror off my tv
i'm not doing that come on
dirty [ __ ]
yeah man there's some dirty [ __ ] out
there man it's uh it's [ __ ] up man
yeah i don't get why you can't just do
something else with the condom i'll be
honest yeah put it like have a shoe box
put on your bed like video we don't
really believe this is real i don't but
i believe it has happened though yes i
did i just believe it really yeah
so they probably ordered them they
believe everything yeah yeah yeah they
order room service yeah the room service
comes with the little condiments and
they probably
i believe that 100
because allegedly he probably does take
his condoms away after he [ __ ]
how do you think he rolls it off you
ever think about that like
when you're when you're thinking about
drake like you ever think about how he
rolls up
like when he finally gets
rolling it off
i gotta roll my [ __ ] off you could just
take yours off son you
pull
i should be staying on in my mind
you can just pull a comment
you've got to get stuck inside so happy
new year
in the [ __ ] and i just put the hot
sauce directly yeah i know hot sauce
direct in the [ __ ]
[ __ ] wall guys hot sauce white sauce
come on dawg did it go off in the middle
of the laugh okay good good then we're
good all right and we're back we're back
we're back hot sauce white sauce was a
good line
my mic didn't go out
yeah it was good
okay uh but it cut off during my laugh
i appreciate it guys it's okay it was
funny i laughed
everybody just it was okay
um
okay so we don't actually believe this
is real but we do believe that there's
real logic to it yes
you i think you believe it's real i
believe it's
not real but it does add up okay i will
say something and this is the genius of
drake to lean into it real yeah and i
loved it we're talking about it but
here's something interesting one i
started to get like a little uh
i don't know like when i was single and
i had like a little bit lev a little
level of like fame or whatever um and
then
i noticed the switch where like
girls were trying to sleep with me
because that was something that they
thought was cool talk your [ __ ] right
like
like for real right like
instead of me going oh my girl that oh
my god that girl's so hot i want to
sleep with her that's cool they were
going oh my god i like what this guy
does for a living or i'm really into
this guy or famous whatever there's some
famous that would be a cool notch on my
belt you guys famous just to be
equivalent to any hot girl any hockey
percent yeah they're rock stars every
hot girls are rocks 100 100 once that
switched sex switched a little bit for
me as well because you're starting to go
oh [ __ ] i'm kind of getting
conquered here as well right so that's
when you lay in the back so that's why i
started back 100 yeah just lean over
yeah
but no what i was trying to say is
i meant to say lay down
okay
just lay down uh
for ready it's lit right yeah that might
have been a friday
[Laughter]
like when you're getting conquered you'd
lay down your sword i don't know why i
said lean over
it's okay
i know
i'm gay
what i'm trying to understand is that
i started to change a little bit how i
thought of
uh sexual dynamics and how interested i
was in doing something
i wonder if it affects
someone in drake's position
where
now he knows every time someone is
having sex with him it would be great if
they got pregnant not every girl
but it would be really great if they got
pregnant and maybe that's why you see
greg drake with these like
kind of famous or successful women who
are also like man i can't get pregnant
right now like serena williams like i
can't get pregnant right now i got these
tournaments i got this other [ __ ] going
on like the person i do get pregnant
with i want to have a family with i
don't want to just get pregnant on some
side [ __ ] are we talking about the same
drake what do you mean i see him with a
lot of ig hoes that aren't famous
and that might be the case
don't get me wrong that might be the
case i just hear about the public ones
like sometimes you hear about the public
ones he's with and you're like wait a
minute these are like successful
older women sometimes not just like the
average super thought
that you'd see with like a ball play or
something like that yeah right and i'm
wondering if
those girls become more attractive
because there's still something that uh
is this coveted about them like they
don't need your ass
they might want to sleep with you but
they don't even worry about the notch on
your belt yeah it is what it is and then
you get to still like uh be that
conquistador that we all have inside of
us right
you know does that make sense what i'm
saying the thoughts is like i'm gonna
get my nut out i'm drunk it's either
german i will not i'm not
i might as well [ __ ] as opposed to not
[ __ ] yeah but who i'm gonna try to
wife put some time yeah he's gonna chase
rihanna he's gonna he gonna be with
serena he's gonna chase somebody that's
still like
coveted and you'd have to conquer
like emotionally in like you know what i
mean in that sense yeah
i don't know maybe i'm making that up
but i always would hear with like him
with like sex gotta be super weird if
you're that level of famous because
every girl would brag about [ __ ] yeah
there's girls in relationships who are
brag to their significant others you can
no longer do the thing that your biology
puts you on this earth to do
which is like conquest and spread your
seed it shouldn't be easy just to get
laid it should be hard like if you're an
animal you're fighting tooth and nail
every single day to maintain your alpha
yeah your [ __ ] elephant seal or
whatever what is where are you from
there's uh
no but like you know those uh the
elephant seals like you literally see
them in the national geographic [ __ ]
they're like slamming their bodies tusks
and everything like that fighting every
single day yeah just so they can have
sex with the girls around now you don't
gotta fight no more yeah it's just there
like that's gotta [ __ ] you up a little
bit up there 100 free decade yeah
decades we hear about it every album
pretty much
that's a good point
no but so i guess i wonder like if that
mutates what you also
are attracted to
you know what's crazy about that level
of fame that i kind of touched on
earlier but there's so many people that
have a list that their significant other
knows about and it's like i can sleep
with these famous people and you can't
get mad drake is on thousands of those
lists yeah who agrees to that list cucks
but like i always hear that happen like
even in like jokes and [ __ ] i comics
talk about this and i'm like who's
having that comment like let my girl
come up to me with that conversation
are you out your [ __ ] mind after i
paid for this [ __ ] wedding
why don't you invite them you talking
about the hall pass yeah what is this
but do you have a hall pass no
that that you won't say
i just got a haul
this this is a whole hall full of
[ __ ] in that [ __ ] yeah you know
what i mean no but for real like no hall
pass what girl's comfortable enough to
come up to you and be like yo if i got a
chance with this dude i'm doing it your
girl came up and said that [ __ ] it would
be a fight physical fight i don't
wait what i don't think hall passes
apply to like hot girls or famous dudes
oh this is just something like ugly
people do right
as a joke yeah
okay good yeah okay some guy like sells
insurance in omaha he's like yeah dude
if i have a chance to [ __ ] jessica beal
i'm gonna do it yeah yeah what up people
you just watch a clip from our weekly
patreon episode you can support the
flagrancy you can support this
unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join
you should because it's a top 10 patreon
in the [ __ ] world that's right for a
good reason go check out why at
patreon.com flagrant2
all right peace